hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how much fat
you need to consume on a ketogenic diet
per meal okay there's a lot of theories
out there but I have an unfair advantage
because I have a lot of people I can
practice on in my clinic to see what
works and what doesn't work okay let's
show you what works a couple things that
people bring up all the time is is a
ketogenic diet which means you're eating
more fat is that dangerous for your
heart the answer is no it's not in fact
it's not the fat that plugs up your
arteries it's the sugar okay there's
tons and tons of studies I'll put some
links below this fact
okay so ketogenic diets are not
dangerous if you do them correctly the
second question that people say or
they've heard they say well the more fat
that you eat the more fat you're going
to burn that's another myth because you
could be burning the dietary fat and not
your own fat all right now the whole
concept of a ketogenic is that you're
having very low carbs okay moderate
protein higher fat what I found is we
want zero sugar unlimited vegetables in
fact we need more vegetables because if
you do this ketones are acidic and the
ketones can potentially raise your pH
and you can end up with either gout it's
type of arthritis or kidney stones okay
so the way to prevent that is to consume
a lot of vegetables and also lemon lemon
actually prevents kidney stones the
other key is that don't consume sugar
with fat why because it will increase
insulin even more so we don't want to
add the sugar to this eating plan at all
the other point is you want to do this
gradually if you're increasing fats too
quickly it's going to overwhelm the
gallbladder and you're going to have
right shoulder pain okay and bloating
things like that
that's why I recommend that if you're
going to do this highly recommend the
gallbladder formula because that gives
you the enzymes and the bile to help
handle this fat in the transition number
two or number three
is that it does take time to adapt your
body to fat-burning all the cells must
change their enzyme structure their
machinery to handle this new fuel source
because we're limited in the glucose and
we're increasing the fat and it does
take sometimes between two three four
five even six weeks to make this
transition in the process we're going to
do this nice and gradually so your body
can go right into it and you'll feel
really good now let's talk about how
much fat that you really need now these
are lists of fats that you can
potentially consume and by the way I
have a link that I'm creating below so
you can download this chart which
actually is right here this one right
here so basically this is kind of a
short version heavy cream 1 tablespoon
is 5 grams of fat ok so an average
person and this is very general needs
between 20 and 40 grams of fat per meal
ok on a ketogenic diet so this is 40
would be the high scale someone really
large it's been doing in a while 20 is
someone smaller and they're just
starting out ok so we're going to
calculate this kind of a mid-range at 30
grams ok just to give you an average so
heavy cream and you could make whipping
cream I have a video on that you can
make all sorts of things with heavy
cream 5 grams you would do six
tablespoons per meal like you're going
to have that right after the meal as
you're fat the fats could allow you to
go longer so you're not as hungry and
it's not going to increase insulin is
exactly what we want and you may only be
doing two meals so if you're concerned
about calories which I actually did add
calories to this you know do two meals
especially if you're not working out I
mean you'll find that once you adapt you
can burn your body fat as a fuel source
and you can go a long period of time
without having to worry about it now egg
is 5 grams of fat now realize that these
there might be four more than 5 grams
for the egg but we're talking 5 grams of
fat so one egg is 5 grams so you
three to four eggs per meal I do four
eggs in the morning sometimes people do
through or three that's totally fine
because you don't have to you can
combine these in certain ways so now
let's get to the beef we got three
ounces is 16 grams so about you know 3
to 6 ounces of beef so what I want to
show you it's kind of an example of this
beef that's frozen right here this is
some beef that's 85% lean I do not buy
the 90 percent lean I like the 80
percent but it's hard to find it I like
this thing to be more fat but this is
the type I have which is grass-fed
organic beef and just so you know I do
the pasture-raised
organic eggs that's the type of eggs
that you need to consume and so then we
get coconut oil right
one tablespoon is 14 grams so we're just
going to double that and have two
tablespoons now you can put that on your
vegetables you can make little treats
there's all sorts of recipes you can
make but that's the type of amount of
fat that you would need per meal brie
cheese 3 ounces 28 grams so you just do
3 ounces so I'll show you
brie cheese is very high in fat and I I
actually took this and I drew these
little lines here to show you what 3
ounces is just to give you an idea it's
a little slice of this this is like 4 3
ounce sections this is 12 ounces of
cheese and one of these for a meal would
give you enough fat but this also has
the protein so you could kill two birds
with one stone and I do a lot of cheese
another idea here's some other cheese
right here this is a German cheese just
less than half of this is 3 ounces okay
so that gives you an idea it's kind of
like a little bit bigger than ah it's
kind of like a yeah it's not a card deck
but it's a little bigger than the palm
of your hand but half of this would be 3
ounces okay just to give you an idea
almond butter 1 tablespoon is 10 grams
so that would be 3 tablespoons of almond
butter that you would consume you can do
that right after
you know that would be your fat olive
oil with 1 tablespoon 14 grams so 2
tablespoons of olive oil that's really
easy just to put on your salad boom
you're done of course some of us going
to end up in the bottom so maybe you
want to add another one but that would
give you about 30 grams of fat P cons so
10 P cons is 20 grams so if you do 25 15
P cons right at the end of a meal or
maybe macadamia nuts that would be
giving that would give you enough fat
ice cream now you're saying wait a
second ice cream can I have ice cream
there are certain ice creams that have
no sugar in fact I'll show you the one
that I have right here so I put a
chocolate brownie on here that's a
recipe that we have in some of the
videos and ice cream and you can
basically make this ice cream or get it
from the store and it has no sugar and
that will one cup would give you 22
grams of fat okay now I personally this
is an ice cream that I'm developing
right now I'm having my own line of ice
cream now I'm experimenting right now
and it's not perfected I'm in the rnd
stage in fact a couple days ago I had
all my staff consume this much ice cream
so I gave them a container because I
wanted to see what would happen right
half of the group had some digestive
bloating and there's temporary but still
it's not perfected yet so we're gonna be
perfecting this I have to go back to R&D
and figure out how I'm gonna fix that
because the last thing I'm going to do
is have you get it and have you bloating
and call me up and say dr. Berg you know
he asked me out that's I don't want to
go there so the ice cream is made with a
high-quality fat no sugar but we have to
figure out the size fibers in there so
we're working on that right now but that
will be down the road some people want
to know when it's going to be I don't
know I'm gonna have it done when I
perfect it okay
so this will give you an idea if you
download the chart below it'll give you
an idea of how much fat
that you really need so go ahead and
apply this and go ahead and write your
comments below and I hope this helped
you I'll see in the next video hey guys
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it please click the share
button below and I will see you in the
next video